vamos a resolver algunos ejemplos de
exponentes o productos de exponentes
elevados a distintas potencias en
particular trabajaremos con exponentes
enteros digamos que tenemos tres a la
menos 8 x 7 al cubo todo esto elevado a
menos 2 y los invitó a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta
hay varias formas en las que podemos
resolver esto pero hay un punto
importante que debemos tener en cuenta y
es que si tenemos el producto de dos
cosas que están elevadas a cierto tipo
de exponente va a hacer lo mismo que
elevar cada una de estas cosas a sus
exponentes y después realizar el
producto esto va a hacer lo mismo que
tener tres a la menos 8 y a su vez esto
elevado a la menos 2 por 7 al cubo
elevado a menos 2
y si queremos simplificar esto 3 a la
menos 8 y a su vez a la menos 2
usaremos la otra propiedad de los
exponentes en el que si tenemos un
exponente elevado a otro exponente lo
que vamos a hacer simplemente es
multiplicar ambos exponentes así que
esto será 3 a la menos 8 x menos dos y
menos 8 x menos dos es 16 positivo así
que esto es 3 a la 16 positivo y ahora
esta parte de aquí 7 al cubo elevado a
su vez al menos 2 va a ser 7 elevado a 3
x menos 2
qué es 7 al menos 6 y esto es lo más que
podemos simplificar lo podemos
reescribirlo de formas diferentes por
ejemplo 7 a la menos 6 es lo mismo que 1
sobre 7 a las 6 así que podemos
escribirlo 3 a la 16 entre 7 a las 6
estos dos son equivalentes y hay otras
formas en las que pudimos resolver esto
por ejemplo pudimos decir que esto de 3
a la menos 8 es lo mismo que uno sobre 3
a la 8 por lo que esto es igual a 7 al
cubo sobre 3 a la 8 y después elevar
esto a menos 2 y con esto elevaríamos el
numerador a la menos 2 y el denominador
a la menos 2 lo que nos daría
exactamente esto de aquí
hagamos otro problema ahora tenemos a la
menos dos por ocho a las siete
todo esto elevado a la segunda potencia
de igual manera que en el ejemplo
anterior puedo elevar cada uno de estos
a la segunda potencia esto es igual a aa
la menos 2 elevado a la segunda potencia
x esto a la segunda potencia 8 a la 7 a
su vez elevado a la 2 eso nos da 2 x
menos 2 es menos 4 a la menos cuatro por
8 elevado a 7 por 2 14 en otros vídeos
vemos más a detalle el por qué esto
funciona aquí tenemos 8 a las 7 x 8 a
las 7 y después sumamos esos dos
exponentes que nos da el 14 lo que nos
da 8 a la 14 así que en este caso para
conocer la cantidad del exponente
sumamos los exponentes las veces que
indica aquí o simplemente hacemos la
multiplicación de estos 2
espero no haberlos confundido con esto
la idea general es que si tenemos algo
elevado a un exponente que a su vez está
elevado a otro exponente simplemente
multiplicamos ambos exponentes hagamos
otro ejemplo más en donde trabajemos con
cocientes digamos que tenemos 2 a la
menos 10 sobre 4 al cuadrado
todo esto elevado a la séptima potencia
esto es lo mismo que tener 2 a la menos
10 elevado a la séptima sobre 4 al
cuadrado elevado a la séptima potencia
si tenemos la diferencia entre dos cosas
y la elevamos a cierta potencia va a ser
lo mismo que elevar el numerador a esa
potencia y el denominador también
elevarlo a esa misma potencia cuál será
nuestro numerador ya hemos hecho esto
antes será 2 a la menos 10 por 7 que es
lo mismo que 2 elevado a la potencia
menos 70 y en el denominador tenemos 4 a
la segunda potencia y a su vez a la
séptima potencia multiplicamos 7 por 2 1
edad 4 elevado a la potencia 14 y
podemos simplificar esto aún más hay
varias formas en las que puedo
simplificar el denominador una de ellas
es darnos cuenta de que 4 es una
potencia de 2 así que puedo reescribir
esto de esta manera 2 a la menos 70
entre 2 a la 2 y a su vez esto elevado a
la 14 4 es lo mismo que 2 al cuadrado
así que puedo reescribir esto como 2 a
la menos 70 entre 2 al cuadrado y a su
vez elevado a la potencia 14 pues nos da
2 a la 28 ahora podemos simplificar más
esto y nos queda que es igual a 2
elevado a recordemos que si tenemos un
cociente con la misma base
puedo restar los exponentes así que me
quedan dos a la menos 70 menos 28 por lo
que finalmente nos queda 2 a la potencia
menos 98 que es otra manera de ver esta
misma expresión